when you think about it
jeff bezos is kind of like santa claus
seriously
think about it you wish for something
you prove you've been good by being a
prime member
you click the buy button and in the next
24 hours you hear your doorbell ring
you go outside and it's exactly what you
wished for with your name on it
sitting on your porch the concept of
santa claus making deliveries to every
kid
all in one day using reindeer in a big
bag is such an enormous task that it
takes kids just a few years to figure
out that it's a myth
oops however what amazon prime one day
deliveries entail is far more complex
and mind-boggling than the bearded man
who likes red
and giving people free things no not
this guy
ah yes anyway how does amazon manage to
pull off several of these one-day santa
light deliveries
every single day of the year without
stopping let's find out but first
welcome back to our channel if you
haven't already make sure to hit the
subscribe button and ring that bell
so you're notified every time we upload
a new video
alright now the first thing you should
know is that your delivery starts even
before you make an
order that's right even before you
complete an order
and even before you click the add to
cart or buy button
your order has already started moving
this is why this video will be divided
into two big parts
what happens before you click for a
package and what happens after you make
your demand
so let's dive into bc before the click
and there's three main things you have
to understand first is that not all
packages are delivered by amazon
second is the size of the packages vary
and third
is that amazon cannot have every single
possible product in every warehouse that
they own
these factors determine what products
can actually be delivered in one day
and they also influence how amazon
orients its processes
to deliver so quickly the most important
factor before a customer clicks
is the fact that they can't have all the
possible products in a warehouse
and this is where their predictive
algorithm comes in you see
like i said earlier before you click a
button your delivery has already begun
this is made possible because the
company makes use of amazon forecast to
predict the likely products that are hot
in a particular region
at a particular time this process
involves the implementation of machine
learning
on some time series data and other
variables to produce accurate forecasts
for instance as a loose stereotype on
amazon you could be more likely to
find shorts sunscreen and apparently
socks for tourists in florida
than you'll find in say alaska of course
it's more nuanced than that as amazon
forecast is as precise as it can be
this tool is used by other companies as
well like more retail
and swiggy in india and axiom telecom
omnis
and a plan among others this forecasting
process is crucial and not just in
single deliveries
but also in periods of time and culture
as it helped amazon correctly predict
the need for lots of face masks in
january of 2020
at this point you begin to wonder if you
have free will
then again there's no way the algorithm
could predict people going crazy for
toilet paper in march of the same year
so yeah so the products for specific
warehouses are selected and transported
accordingly
the products most of which are provided
by amazon make their way to the
warehouse which is called the
fulfillment center
or fc for short they are taken in at the
receiving area
unpacked and scanned before being staged
to the bins of the shelves
even the staging of the procedures in
the shelves is assisted by deep machine
learning
that pervades all the processes of the
warehouse when the associate at the
staging area scans the barcode on the
product
the system highlights bins of the shelf
with magenta lights
indicating that the product must not go
in that bin either for weight
distribution reasons
or just because there are similar
products in that bin and it's not
optimal for randomizing the placement
process
the rest of the processes in the
fulfillment center are just pure poetry
with the lines and strategic placement
of robots and humans
and the implementation of high tech
making everything rhyme like a good poem
would
after scanning the warehouse now has an
inventory of the millions of products in
it and where exactly they are
making use of amazon aurora an amazon
web service tool
they maintain a flawless relational
database to make picking the products
easy
and this helps because instead of having
a section of different types of goods
they have figured out that it is better
to randomize the products as much as
possible
to make picking faster so amazon aurora
and amazon neptune help keep track of
all this
now let's move on to the a d of our
video the after demand processes
this is the things happening after you
have made your order so we have millions
of products all
arranged randomly into different shelves
covering thousands of square feet in the
warehouse
how does the exact product you just
ordered get out of this mess
into a box and on your porch in the next
24 hours
first of all meet kiva these guys are
the kings of the stowing
area like the ants in an anthill they
are robots designed for the movement of
the shelves from the steering area to
the pickers after you click a button
that's right your order sets these guys
in motion they were created by mick
mounts
founder of kiva systems which was
brought to amazon for 775 million
dollars in 2012
and is now known as amazon robotics as a
side note
alibaba warehouses also uses these types
of robots from quicktron robotics
in the amazon fcs the floors in the
stowing area are marked by barcodes
these barcodes are scanned by the kivas
as they move to help them know where
they are
and where to go also this network of
information helps guide the robots on
how to move to avoid traffic and
collision
speed up slow down the works the pegasus
the latest model can lift over 1
200 pounds and move at a comfortable
walking speed of 3 miles per hour this
has helped increase the holding capacity
of the warehouses by 50
as well as making the retrieval of these
products three times faster
overall this makes the fulfillment cost
for products as low as 40 percent its
initial cost
and more importantly the pictures don't
have to walk up to 12 miles per shift
in warehouses that are as large as 10 to
20 football fields
nowadays they're bawling and if a
product falls off a shelf in the stowing
area
the system alerts the control center so
that an authorized associate is sent
into the area
the associate wears a vest that emits a
radio pulse and creates a path
so that all the kivas avoid that route
until the associate has found the
product
fix it up and leave the stowing area
what's more the robots also use machine
learning so that when a product seems to
be hot and people keep ordering they
stay closer to the areas that the system
has identified more of those products to
be present
the robots charge themselves when low
and know how to orient the shelves for
the picking to be easy for the associate
it's very organized and routine so that
the workers are ironically
like robots themselves but it's
beautiful to watch if you're not the one
doing it after being packed and dropped
into totes the products are sorted from
the totes into respective packages at
the packing area
and even packaging is automated as the
size of the box
length of tape protective material and
barcode label are all decided by
wait for it machine learning from there
the box moves to the slam machine
where your name and address are added
and the best logistics for your package
is selected using
wait for it machine learning slam
actually stands for scan label apply
and manifest the package is sent to a
sortation center where it's picked up
for last mile delivery
the amazon trucks and amazon flex
drivers are guided to your house using
hear maps and navigation systems instead
of google maps or apple maps
thank god for that sometimes deliveries
can be tedious for the drivers and there
have been complaints every now and then
in fact some of you in the comments will
also probably say similar things
apparently despite all the deep learning
amazon cannot predict what's needed by
their workers
to be honest it's quite difficult to run
the human side of anything perfectly
because the fact is when you make a
one-day order amazon is committed to
fulfilling that order
so you're not exactly innocent however
there are plans for introducing
technology that will give this a more
humane feel
ironically by eliminating the humans
exactly what robots have always been
feared for
the biggest example is the approval by
the faa for drone test runs that will
deliver packages under five pounds to
customers
this will make the reality of 30 minute
deliveries the new normal as this weight
class makes up the bulk of amazon
deliveries
who knows maybe in the future kids will
think that the amazon rainforest was
named after the company
this level of clout is only possible
because amazon utilizes the wealth of
resources from its other sectors like
amazon web services
its robotics and its logistics to slowly
beat its commerce competitors like
walmart
best buy and target from the little
online website for purchasing books
amazon has become one of the all-time
best sellers
of products in the world not just new
york and their complex delivery system
is just one example of proper
implementation of 21st century tech
and innovation to provide the best
possible services to people
do you think they'll edge out the likes
of walmart as the undisputed online
retailer
or do you think that is far-fetched what
do you think of the delivery drones
and also what do you want for christmas
this year let us know in the comments
below
mr bezos reads them and if you enjoyed
this video make sure to give it a like
and check out more awesome ones in the
simply tech channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time